salut aujourd'hui je devais tourner chez
moi et il ya un bon oui pas possible
chez moi je suis donc obligé de revenir
faire la vidéo au bureau et apparemment
il ya du bruit aussi c'est parfait pour
bien commencer cette semaine on va
parler de comment retenir ses rêves
d'entre vous pensent sûrement qu'ils ne
se souviennent pas de ses rêves le matin
il se réveille du ballon j'ai par et les
cp aujourd'hui à l'aide de toutes les
études qui ont été faites on sait dont
on rêve tous la plupart des mammifères
également rêve le problème c'est de se
rappeler le matin la première chose
c'est de préparer son esprit à rêver du
mois se souvenir juste avant de vous
endormir avant de vous coucher vous vous
rappelez que vous avez envie de vous
rappeler du rêve justement répéter ou en
boucle dans votre tête je veux me
souvenir de mon rêve je veux me rappeler
de mon rêve je me souvenir de mon rêve
demain matin c'est quelque chose que
vous allez tellement ancrée en vous
qu'au bout de quelques jours quelques
semaines pour certains vous allez déjà
spontanément vous souvenir je rêvais de
quoi un geek un ça me revient avec cette
première étape vous n'allez pas
forcément bien vous rappelez du rêve
vous allez l'attraper en fait à voir
quelques images quelques sensations
quelques mots peut-être l'action
principale et ça c'est un bon point de
départ
en général on se souviens pas très bien
des rêves parce que le réveil sonne ça
nous coupe complètement et on passe tout
de suite à autre chose mais si on prend
un peu plus le temps on s'en souvient
mieux lors des relais naturel qu'on a le
matin ou dans la nuit
c'est très frais dans notre esprit
seulement notre cerveau est configuré
pour oublier rapidement le rêve c'est un
processus de protection pour qu'on ne
confonde pas ce qu'on arrivait avec la
réalité je sais pas si ça vous est déjà
arrivé moi ça m'est arrivé de rêver de
quelqu'un que je connais un ami qui me
fait plutôt une crasse durant le rêve et
le lendemain je lui en veux un petit peu
de gens me même beaucoup alors que c'est
qu'un rêve c'est une projection de mon
inconscient pour les animaux c'est
pareil vous avez peut-être déjà vu un
chien rêver comme dans tous les rêves ya
une problématique est un enjeu aussi à
se trouver d'un train de courir après un
chat et le moment où il va ouvrir les
yeux faut pas qu'ils pensent que c'était
vrai et qui se rend maître à courir a
cherché le chat c'est pour ça qu'on
évacue le rêve
vous avez juste quelques secondes pour
consolider un petit peu ce souvenir donc
quand vous vous réveillez peut-être en
pleine nuit ou le matin sans réveil
n'ouvrait pas directement les yeux
rappelez-vous le rêve essayer de
remonter le plus possible de d'en
essayer de tout revoir de repasser les
scènes sans vous rendormir sinon vous
allez jug ajouté et je vous souhaite et
c'est à vous allez retourner dans le
même rêve ce qui peut être cool aussi
quand la vtb la deuxième étape qui
paraît la plus simple c'est de noter son
rêve de l'écrire alors
est vrai et c'est pas tout à fait vrai
parce que vous allez sortir du rêve et
donc il va arriver un petit peu passé le
mieux c'est vraiment de ressasser tout
ça mentalement et de prendre des
éléments clés du rêve pour s'en souvenir
lors de votre prochain réveil ou dc 10
minutes quand vous serez un petit peu
plus dispo si vous êtes entraîné les
techniques du palais mental que vous
avez présenté à l'est dans la playlist
de la mémoire alors placez-y quelques
images clés si par exemple mon rêve
c'était allez disons un rêve que j'ai
fait j'ai rêvé que j'étais dans le
garage de chez mes parents en train
d'improviser un nouveau texte
alors je sais pas pourquoi il y avait un
grand étang dollars à linge et je
faisais les blagues dessus et les
quelques personnes qui étaient devant
moi étaient mortes de ré et quand je me
suis réveillé j'étais pas capable
d'analyser si c'était bien ou pas mais
je me souvenais qu'il fallait que je me
rappelle de tout ça parce qu'il y avait
peut-être un potentiel à exploiter
bon en réalité pas du tout c'était
vraiment pourri mais c'est pas le
provost pour me souvenir de tout ça de
gmi dans une partie de mon balai mental
c'est une partie ou g5 spot 5 points ou
mettre des images je me suis rappelé du
garage de mes parents je me suis rappelé
de l'étendoir je me suis rappelé de la
valise parce que je faisais aussi des
blagues sur ma valise je n'ai même pas
voulu faire un tellement c'est pourri
c'est même pas des blagues en soit je le
dis j'ai mis comme image aussi la vision
de toute ma famille dans le garage en
train de me regarder et j'ai mis aussi
l'image d'un théâtre pour me rappeler du
propos et c'est vrai j'avais aussi
l'image de jean marie bigard parce qu'il
venait un moment donné à la fin pour me
dire que c'était bien et c'était
vraiment 2010 quand même je faisais par
exemple ou des blagues c'est pas
vraiment une blague hein ne me jugez pas
là dessus j'expliquais que quand on se
prenait les pieds dans l'étendoir à
linge ça faisait super mal et c'était
terrible et après je parlais de ma
valise qui m'accompagne toujours en
tournée en dix ans mais ça c'est ma
meilleure amie
mais des fois elle traîne un peu parce
qu'elle est lourde elle est trop lourde
je sais pas pourquoi j'ai rêvé de ça je
sais pas sûrement comme je suis en train
d'écrire en ce moment je dois être un
petit peu aux stress et de chercher des
idées ce qui était ouvre c'est que je me
suis créé tout ça dans le palais mental
donc c'est ce que je vous recommande de
faire pour mieux vous rappelez et plus
tard quand je me suis levé sur mon
second réveil j'ai fait remonter tout ça
pour l'écrire justement j'étais remonté
voulait dire remontée pour l'écrire noir
sur blanc et avoir une vision globale et
me rappeler c'est là que j'ai pu
analyser réellement le contenu et que
c'était bien père av
ce ne sera donc pas dans le nouveau
spectacle l'importance de placer des
images qui dans votre palais mental ou
dans un autre système de mémoire sans
même ouvrir les yeux en reste encore
calme détendue dans le
tranquille c'est ne pas faire monter une
excitation vous qui feraient fuir le
souvenir du rêve et vous permettre plus
tard en état d'éveil complet de vous
rappeler concrètement tous le rêve où
tous les rêves que vous avez fait plus
vous allez faire ça mieux vous allez
vous souvenir de vos rêves et se
souvenir de ses rêves c'est cool ça
permet d'être plus créatifs ensuite plus
imaginatif de mieux se connaître soi
même
la dernière étape ultime pour faire ces
trois choses là et même le reste parce
que on s'est aperçu communion soudaine
ses rêves qu'on devenait calme parce
qu'on comprenait un petit peu comment on
marche et inconsciemment la dernière
étape ultime donc c'est de tenir un
journal des rêves votre rituel quotidien
après votre réveil sera de noter un
maximum d'informations sur les rêves que
vous avez fait durant la nuit et vous
allez pouvoir en relisant ça avoir de
nouvelles idées être plus créatif plus
serein plus calme que pour certains
parce que vous allez comprendre un petit
peu quels sont vos problèmes que vous
n'osiez peut-être pas vous avouer où vos
désirs cachés et au final vous allez
mieux vous comprendrez mieux explorer
votre inconscient je vous fais cette
vidéo très tôt ce matin parce que ce
soir je suis au festival drôles de
zèbres à strasbourg je joue juste avant
yann stotz et cécile giroud si jamais
vous êtes là bas et que vous prenez vos
places je sais pas s'il en reste ou pas
en tout cas on se verra à la toute fin
de soirée avec plaisir merci beaucoup
d'avoir regardé la vidéo jusque là
j'espère que ça vous a plu n'oubliez pas
de laisser un petit pouce en l'air avant
de partir ça coûte pas grand chose pour
vous et c'est important pour nous dire
une chanson un petit peu ça si vous êtes
abonné n'oubliez pas d'activer la cloche
comme ça c'est en train d'apparaître là
juste en dessous si vous n'êtes pas
abonné vous pouvez le faire en cliquant
ici
voilà c'est aussi simple que ça parce
que mentalement que c'est une vidéo par
jour depuis le 1er janvier jusqu'au 31
décembre donc rendez vous demain à 17
heures ciao
font du bruit dehors et sinon j'avais
dit ciao
[Musique]